by the way what was it like I have to
ask because I'm watching House of dragon
what was Matt Smith like he was like
method
so he didn't really talk to you very
much not really not really well I mean
yeah was he nice enough you know he was
nice but it was he was just Charles
Manson so
he was meant
um like you know what I mean he was
really like in the character and the
character is um like gregarious and
charismatic and talkative and crazy and
that so it's not so in between takes he
was kind of quiet because I'm sure it
was exhausting he did a [ __ ] amazing
Charles Manson you gotta watch it Matt
Smith is an incredible actor I think
like seriously I think it's amazing and
I think for them to cast him as Charles
Manson was a bit of like a surprising
Choice it's not like the first person
you'd think of but he did such a good
job with the voice and the guitar
playing and the singing yeah I think
it's a it's kind of an interesting movie
you know it's done by the women who did
American Psycho America oh wow yeah yeah
so it's like it's it's an interesting
movie and we shot it at a place that
looked
I mean it was in Santa Clarita but it
looked identical to the ranch so it was
very creepy and we used like real rotten
food like there was nothing real
cigarettes there was nothing like fake
about it wow I read to be Charles Manson
did you you did for that one yeah yeah
it did not go well well I don't think
that's the one for you
I I uh only got that part because
um someone dropped out so I found out
about it the day before the table read
and I was like [ __ ] dude
yeah did he improvise at all Matt yeah
yeah was he like kind of like a
dangerous thing were you enamored by it
or you're like holy [ __ ] this guy's like
on fire it was amazing it was wonderful
like it he um okay so I'm not good at
improvising it makes me feel like
uncomfortable and scared
especially when I have to like monologue
you know what I mean but he monologued
like like but like in what Charles
Manson would say yeah man yeah we're
gonna do this man I'm moving yes exactly
yeah and you know who else was really
good in that movie is Chase Crawford he
was great
um and it was wild experience Charlie
says you know